a strip of paper a paper ribbon and two
ordinary paper clips we mend the paper
strip in a Z or s shape like so you know
going winding about like that and with
the help of the paper clips
we shall fix that shape by slotting the
paper clips here and here now what
happens if I start pulling the ends of
the paper well you can see that the
paper clips come closer and closer
together because they're being driven by
the paper so if I keep pulling
eventually they'll touch and jam but if
I keep pulling on the rest they hope and
when I pick them up they are linked
that's quite interesting they're linked
what we have just done is with two paper
clips only and this is what we shall
call version about zero this is just the
beginning the trick goes back quite a
long way according to Martin Gardner's
encyclopedia of impromptu magic this
seems have been discovered by somebody
called Bowman in Washington State today
we'll do some variations on this so we
fix the shape of the bending paper like
so but this time we added a rubber band
you see the paper has two loops here and
here and seen from your side we are
hanging the rubber band on the Left loop
this is version number one version
number one then hanging over here what
happens this time this time what happens
is this you have the rubber band hanging
from the paper ribbon underneath clip
clip together from the rubber band we
have this kind of half chain and you see
in a moment why we call it half chain of
rubber band clip clip together
in science you have to exercise your
power of imagination and observation
especially and you know you can't just
take something and say oh this is not
going better and they rejected little
differences of innocuous appearance
maybe you have to pay a lot of attention
to such little differences to illustrate
the point let's do something that looks
like version number one which you have
just try but isn't quite number one that
we have just tried looked like this the
Rubberbandits
hanging from the left loop of those two
loops okay
now the rubber band is now hanging from
the right loop instead of left loop and
that's what we shall call version number
two you see before he was hanging here
and now it's hanging here
so that's verse number two what's going
to happen if I pull the ends of the
paper well you know somebody not
observant might say what's the
difference in here here well probably
doesn't matter well but you remember
that version about one ended up having
the rubber band hanging from the paper
ribbon with two paper clips hanging from
the road band this time version number
two whole thing falls off the paper
ribbon so that's different
nonetheless when you pick it up you
still get this clip clip rub and this
half chain together so in the case of
version number one we had this and
version number two this got detached
having tried verse number one and
version number two it becomes tempting
indeed irresistible to try both at the
same time what is one plus two well it's
very lucky that I have another rubber
band here I think and I'm sure using two
one plus two should look like this you
see because by itself this rubber band
this one is in the pollution version
number one it's hanging from the left
this one by itself is in the position
version number two so one plus two
should be like this it's doing one and
two at the same time so the question is
what happens if I pull the ends of the
paper what's going to happen to the two
rubber bands this time and two paper
clips before we do that however let me
debunk myself a little bit the fact that
in the version number one the rubber
band stayed on the paper and number two
the rubber band full fell off the paper
is in fact no mystery we can understand
it so let's try to understand ER by
ignoring the paper clips
you remember that version number one he
looked like this the rubber nose hanging
from the paper on the left loop if you
look carefully you see that the paper
strip goes through the rubber band and
then passes on the side in other words
the rubber band is linked with the paper
strip so if I pull the ends of the paper
of course
he stays linked and he has no choice but
to stay on the paper that is why in
version number one the rubber band
stayed on the paper
in contrast version number two looked
like this over the two loops in the
paper he was hanging from the right loop
if you look carefully you see that the
paper comes into the rubber band but
goes back out yeah so the rubber band is
in fact not to link to the paper when I
pull the ends then being uh nicked the
band is free to fall that is why the
rubber band can fall off the paper in
version number two so the fact that the
version number one stays on the paper
number two falls off the paper is no
mystery as I said that's a purely
topological thing that we can understand
let's go back then where we left off and
try to do one plus two so what's going
to happen if we do one and two at the
same time you should pause and try to
guess they are all going to be linked
and on
the paper good but more a bit more
precisely we throw one big long chain
long chain rubberband clip-clip rub and
in the can order or rubberband clip
rubberband clip or maybe two rubber
bands get linked where I do that pony
for money and I don't know I picture my
guess is is rubberband
paperclip paperclip rubberband excellent
okay so that's quite nice by the way
it's always important to guess anyway
because you know guessing is really the
way to learn and in fact I advanced in
science both for students and
researchers alike because if you guess
right you're very very proud and you got
it right and if you guessed it wrong you
are really shocked maybe not really but
slightly shocked and that engages your
thinking and you can learn what happened
and then it makes you a little smarter
next slide so always guess before
solving any problem okay let's try doing
this my friend Brady just rubber band
clip clip rubber band let's do this one
plus two what's going to happen here we
go of course that's what happens
congratulations and it makes sense in
retrospect because if we didn't have
this rubber band you see that
configuration the remaining
configuration is of course the number
one configuration if we didn't have this
red line well you get clipped click
brother and hanging that's number two
but that would be because this robe and
is not present would be detached from
the paper so everything will fall down
so together you'll get this long chain
when we hear about computation or
calculation in general we always think
naturally because that's how we learn
these things in school and about numbers
calculating numbers all perhaps at the
more advanced level calculating with
formulas and you know you do some
algorithm you do some recipe and then
the expected results come out but here
your brain although it hasn't formalized
anything you know he hasn't written any
numbers or all formulas has effectively
computed it has caught on to something
some really rich pattern in nature and
has started understanding what was going
to happen so it's quite curious that
your brain is good at computing even
without numbers or formulas okay what
happens if I take two copies of number
one on this paper ribbon and do the same
experiment all in the ends one plus one
looks like this you see this rubber band
is in the position of now familiar
position number one this rubber band the
top one as you can see by looking at it
from the back is another copy of version
number one so we have here two copies of
version number one leaving together on
this strip of paper and you can see that
both of those rubber bands are linked to
the paper in the sense that the paper
goes through one and through the other
so when I pull the ends the rubber bands
must stay on the paper that much we know
the only question is how do they
interact with the paper clips
you can't guess I think both rubber
bands are going to stay on the paper
that's true and the two paper clips will
be linked to each of them on the air how
about the paper clips between themselves
I think it'll be rubber band paper clip
paper clip rubber band ah that's good
indeed either we are guessing that we
again get that long change of band clip
done let's try this
indeed of course again we thought nature
should behave in a certain way and
nature obliged you get this kind of
suspension bridge rubber bands are on
the paper that we had already understood
topologically but what is new is that
you get again this long chain the band
clip good band hanging like this
paperclips connecting the rubber bands
in the middle in this engine
configuration
that's 1 plus 1 so 1 plus 2 is like this
because number 1 is an included paper
number two isn't and 1 plus 1 was like
this because they're both copies or
number 1 and they have to be on paper
each time then we are getting a long
chain or full chain of band click band
and the only question is how that long
chain is positioned with respect to the
paper well it remains for us to try 2
plus 2 version number 2 I'd like to
recall is the one where by itself fell
off the paper 2 plus 2 is like this and
that's because if you look at for
example just this rubber band that's in
the now-familiar and positional number 2
paper goes in but comes back out and
over here at the top you see another
copy of version number 2 ok so what we
have to do is to pull the ends and see
what happens
well this time neither a brand by itself
is linked to the paper so what's going
to happen when I was exploring this and
trying various possibilities a song at
this stage when I came to this stage for
the first time naturally I guess that I
would get a long chain of band clip
quick band which we do and because
neither a band is linked to the paper I
thought that the entire thing will just
fall down to the ground and leave in the
paper alone so let's try this
this time however something strange has
happened the entire ensemble of the
rubber bands and paper clips didn't fall
down to the ground instead they stayed
on the paper you see there is a rubber
band that goes around the paper like
this in a transverse manner and then
they is in the middle a rubber band with
cheese kind of acting as a lock so to
speak please ignore the paper clips they
are not that interesting at this stage
so there's a middle lock and then the
band that goes around transversely
around the paper you can see that if we
didn't have this rubber band the other
one could be pulled off the paper on the
other hand if we didn't have this rubber
band then this middle lock which is
hanging would fall down to the ground so
neither abadi
is linked to
paper that's true but each one is
preventing the other from leaving the
paper so that if I now close the ends of
this paper and think of the paper as the
third loop we have here a system of
three loops any two of these are
mutually unlinked but three together are
linked and stuck together and that kind
of configuration has a name it is called
a burrow man link or mail link after the
Italian Renaissance family called
Borromeo no no it's not the family who
used to post a monitor that's for sure
that's another family but borer mail and
it appears in all sorts of contexts
very very important a central object for
example in three dimension of apology
here is an example of a Boromir link
each of those three pieces of wood is a
loop rather so distorted loop but it is
a loop nun dress and they're clearly
stuck together you can pull them apart
but you see it's curious to note that if
you make in your mind's eye any one of
these three disappear by saying Kazan
for example let's make the one that I'm
holding disappear then the other two can
be pulled apart right they are not
linked and it's the same for any of
these three so if I make this one
disappear the other two can be pulled
apart and any one of these disappearing
will cause the other two to fall apart
so that is the problem yawning
configuration and this is carved out of
a single piece of wood and when I first
bought it in Africa and I was very
impressed to hear this but then you
caught me that that's the only way to
carve something like this of course good
we have seen quite a few things and if
you want to share this with friends and
family I suggest that you end on the
following rather mischievous note you
say okay okay folks you understand
everything right then by this time
they're feeling very cocky and contented
yeah yeah we understand everything and
you say okay let's revise the first
thing that we started with what happens
if I bend the paper like this in as 0s
shape and with the help of paper clips
fix things in place and then pull the
ends of the paper they say oh we have
seen all that and they get linked
together right and so on it's really
strange because not more than ten
minutes ago they had never seen paper
clips come together man now they assume
that every single time become together
that's quite curious so you say okay
okay but let's try this so paper clips
on paper until when I do aah
that's strange they didn't get linked
together what happened force people
these are some people maybe not you were
distracted by my pattern and having been
watching what we did was indeed to put
the paper clip at the top of this Z
shape but the other one instead of
putting it at the top I put it at the
bottom on the other side so paper clip
here and here so when I pull they are
completely separated there is no
incentive for these to link together so
you have to keep watching but not all is
lost this is just a piece of mystery but
you can start doing science on total
let's fry the paper clips in the wrong
positions but with the addition of the
rubber bands
let's try rubber bands in the position
that we used to call 1+1 in other words
both rubber bands are linked with paper
as far as the rubber bands are concerned
it's just like 1+1 as you can see both
rubber bands and linked to the paper
they have to stay on the paper what's
different from the previous experiment
is that one of the paper clips is at the
top but the other one is at the bottom
he used to be both at the top and both
at the top mysteriously they used to
link but this time the paper clips will
not be linked Rutland's however we have
already understood the topology because
the paper goes through the Rabanne
has to stay on the paper so what's going
to happen when I pull the ends of the
paper huh
any takers any guesses maybe H rather
than will have one paperclip or okay
that's interesting so in my friend Brady
is saying well when I straighten out the
paper rubber bands will be hanging from
anyway but that's that's that's
obligatory each or a band will have a
paperclip this rubber band paper clip
but paper clips do not link because
they're on the wrong sides of the paper
let's try this excellence that's what
happens you see we have started
computing we understand something
there's a lot of method to this madness
interesting that city looks like the
previous one but this time each paper
clips is linked with our band but not
between themselves